the movie starts with the scene of
pollution and how humans are destroying
other species habitats the scene then
shifts to China where a man tells
tourists about different animals he
displays a lizard that makes T-Rex's
Shadows shows a dog and says it's a
tiger he puts chicken wings on top of a
skeleton and says he is Batman he also
offers a mermaid but it's just a doll
inside a fish sensing the fraud everyone
starts demanding a refund he tries to
calm them and takes them to a room to
show something fascinating on reaching
they find a man in a tub dressed as a
mermaid enraged they throw him out and
start beating him next it's shown that
there is an auction going on for an
island where a person named Leu bids the
highest and gets it Le throws a party to
celebrate where all the rich people are
invited Leu welcomes them and tells them
about his recently bought Island
everyone laughs saying dolphins are near
the island sea due to which the island
is of no use Lee replies that he has
already taken permission from the
government to remove Dolphins to which
everyone gets shocked another man
approaches Le to become his business
partner but Leu refuses while Leu is
near the pool enjoying the girls a woman
named Ruan throws her expensive watch
into the pool she says whoever gets it
can have it all the girls jump into the
pool and fight for the watch then Ruan
asks Le to become a partner to which Liu
accepts as they are about to kiss a lady
named Shen comes out of the pool and
interrupts them Le's bodyguard starts
beating up Shen but Le stops them and
seeing this Ruan leaves after this Leu
inquires about Shen she introduces
herself and says that she likes Leo asks
his bodyguard to throw her out but Shan
resists and gives him her contact number
and leaves Shen goes on her skateboard
and stops by the shop where she buys
stuff and eats a lot of chicken after
that she reaches a ship which is their
Temporary Home an old lady is beside the
water someone asks Shan about their plan
to which Shan replies that she gave Li
her number at this point it is revealed
that Shan was sent to Liu on a mission
the next day Leu and his team discuss
the project development on his Island
where they talk about setting up more
powerful sunners than earlier they can
change the frequency and Target
different species the scientist also
tells them they have found another
frequency apart from fishes and dolphins
in the next scene we see that Shan is a
mermaid living together with other
mermaids on the ship they cannot go to
the ocean because of the sonar there is
also an octopus that is half human he
tells her that humans are evil humans
have destroyed habitat by fitting sonar
in the ocean and Liu is blamed for this
they make plans to kill Liu and they
have selected Shen for this as she is
beautiful elsewhere Lee spends some time
with Ruan after the meeting she says
something bitter to Lee regarding their
level of Lifestyle she comes from a
wealthy family but Li is poor before she
also chastises him for saving Shan
earlier hearing this Li calls Shan in
front of Ruan and confirms to pick her
up in 10 minutes which makes Ruan leave
in the meantime everyone is thrilled and
prepared so they take their spot and get
ready to kill Li but instead of Le his
bodyguards are there the octopus takes a
bag full of weapons and hands it to Shan
for her to kill Le Shan is taken to Le's
workplace where she goes through a
security check she is successful in
clearing the security Shan spots Leu and
follows him to kill him she attempts
many times but all her attacks reflect
on herself she gets up again and attacks
Lee with full force this time she gets
hit by a golf stick and faints right
beside L Li gets startled seeing Shen he
makes her sit at a table and reveals
that he called her for no reason he
offers her money and says to leave she
shows no interest in his money instead
says she is hungry and wants Le to feed
her Li gets angry and shouts at Shen but
seeing Ruan he sweetly talks with Shen
and gets ready to feed her food Li
proposes more money to Shan to get rid
of her Shan again refuses and says she
wants chicken in her favorite restaurant
to which Li agrees eventually as they
reach Shan gets herself a chicken but
doesn't see Le anywhere near she starts
searching for Le but not finding him
makes her upset after some time Le
reaches there with his bodyguards Shen
asks him to eat with her at first he
hesitates but they both finish a lot of
chicken together while eating Le gets
emotional and starts crying he shares
his childhood story with Shen that they
were poor tough life because of poverty
made him work hard and he became the
richest man in the country after the
story Leu writes a blank check and gives
it to her annoyed she throws that check
into the fire seeing this Liu becomes
angry and asks her what she wants she
tells him that she likes him and wants
to spend time with him they both have a
fun time together later Le drops her and
says he loves her Shan knows all her
mermaid friends are waiting to kill Le
but she tells her friends she cannot do
it later Liu invites her to his place
again and everyone is sure Shan will
kill him Shan accepts Liu's invitation
and goes to his place Li brings flowers
for Shen and sits together to grab a
meal as Le is surrounded by his
bodyguards he orders them to leave Shan
finds this a good time to kill him but
in the meantime Leu proposes he gives
her a ring and asks her to marry him
Shan gets nervous and tells him that she
is there to kill him but Le refuses to
listen to anything that Shan is saying
and kisses her meanwhile Ruan comes
there so Shan leaves and Li follows her
in the next scene the octopus asks Shan
why she didn't kill Li he suspects that
she has started liking L Shan refuses
this fact to which nobody agrees in the
meantime someone knocks on the door Shan
opens it and sees L who is taken back to
C Shan and her mermaid Avatar along with
many others he immediately tries to
escape but the mermaids hit him and hold
him hostage after Le gains Consciousness
the octopus hitting him complains their
place has been destroyed due to some ARS
Le says he didn't know and will stop if
they let him leave no one trusts him and
the octopus chokes him trying to save Le
Shan Cuts one of the octopus's tentacles
and sets him free she then confesses
that she loves him Le goes to a police
station to complain but no one believes
him in the next scene Shan blames
herself for this and tries to take her
own life but the old mermaid stops her
on the other hand we see Lee with Ruan
and he investigates the effects of sonar
and realizes that it's harming many
species so he goes to his research
Center and asks them to test the sonar
range on him he cannot bear it even a
bit and vomits there then his secretary
says that it is the lowest frequency and
if it's increased it can kill anyone he
immediately calls for an emergency
meeting and asks them to remove all the
sonars but no one agrees fortunately
rulan joins the panel and she agrees
with him because of this all the sonar
are shut down rulan then asks him why he
did this showing his trust in Ruan he
tells her Shan is a mermaid and is
compelled to live with her family on a
ship because they are affected by sonar
she laughs at Leu and goes to a secret
lab where she has been testing on
mermaids for a long time to get their
DNA and become the wealthiest person in
the world Le tries to stop her but
instead she slaps him and says she'll
even kill Shan if he gets in her way in
the next scene Ruan with her team
approaches the ship to catch the
mermaids they start firing in the water
to kill the mermaids and also catch Shen
the eldest mermaid uses her power and
makes everyone fall in the water the
scientist shoots her with the missile
throwing her to the ocean ocean she
realizes that sonars are turned off so
she calls everyone in the ocean hearing
this Shan again trusts Leu as he has
removed all the sonars everyone starts
escaping except Shen who is much behind
they catch her with a stinger but it's
pretty challenging to control her since
they are in the open ocean meanwhile
Ruan comes in a helicopter and shoots
the most powerful missile on Shen
causing her to be thrown on the seashore
everyone surrounds her and Ruan orders
them to kill her as they are about to do
so Le arrives in the nick of time and
saves her he then confronts them by
saying that if someone tries to hurt her
he'll eliminate them everyone puts their
guns down but ran snatches a gun and
shoots her Le jumps to protect her and
saves Shan by dropping her in the ocean
during this incident Shan gets to know
that LE loves her and real after this
the police arrive there and arrest Ruan
and her team in the next scene a young
man comes to meet Lou he asks him why he
donated all his money to protect the
environment Li replies that if there is
no clean water to drink and fresh air to
breathe it would be meaningless no
matter matter how much money you make he
then asks whether mermaids are real to
which Le denies the young man asks him
about his relationship he says that he
is not waiting for anyone and is in a
relationship then a beautiful girl walks
in and it's Shan they are married and
living happily later we see that Shan
and Le are traveling underwater where
other mermaids are also there and the
movie ends